while it's possible to see a character's
death coming from a mile away
sometimes it comes out of nowhere and
leaves audience is shocked other times
our real life factors behind the scenes
and the character's life with that in
mind here's a look at the real reasons
these on-screen lives were ended on
soullow long before the release of 1983
Star Wars Return of the Jedi
Harrison Ford began arguing that his
character han Solo should be killed off
whether is from boredom with the famous
space opera or desire to punch up the
narrative Porter's had a death wish for
Han Solo for decades while talking to
Conan O'Brien Ford reiterated that he
wanted Solo to sacrifice himself to a
high ideal and give a little butter
little gravitas to the enterprise after
decades of waiting ford finally got his
wish
han not only died in Star Wars The Force
awakens but he was killed by a son Ben
solo aka kylo Ren
according to Abrams they needed a big
moment in order to have carlo Ren step
out from Darth Vader's shadow in a Q&A
with Entertainment Weekly Abrams said we
knew we needed to do something bold the
only reason why kylo Ren has any hope of
being a worthy successor is because we
lose one of the most beloved characters
well beloved to everyone except Ferris
and Ford apparently I argued for 30
years for this to happen right and
finally I wore him down agent Zedd
loosely based on the comic series of the
same name
men in black follows Will Smith and
Tommy Lee Jones as a monitor aliens on
earth and protect the planet from
extraterrestrial attack legendary actor
Rip Torn appeared in the movie as agent
Zed the head of the men in black
organization and reprised his role for
the 2002 sequel unfortunately his
character was killed off between the
second and third installments off screen
and replaced by Emma Thompson as Agent
oh it's just so sad Thank You director
Barry Sonnenfeld
told io9 that the reason for Torn's
absence was to keep the movie from
feeling too similar to previous men in
black films according to Sonnenfeld
we didn't want to go back to every
single same character we didn't keep
whipped or nurse dead but I think we
have a new wonderful leader with Emma
Thompson well that may be true there
could be more to the story around the
time men in black 3 started principal
photography Thorne was serving a
two-year suspended sentence for breaking
into a bank
or heavily intoxicated Torn's legal
troubles might have made it just too
complicated to bring the actor back for
the sequel Boba Fett's Boba Fett's made
his big screen debut in Star Wars The
Empire Strikes Back or he'd cut an
imposing silhouettes as one of Darth
Vader's hired bounty hunters although he
barely spoke a word he quickly became a
fan favorite so it was a real surprise
when he was suddenly killed off at the
beginning of Return of the Jedi
according to Craig Miller the former
head of fan relations for Lucasfilm Boba
Fett was originally going to be a much
bigger villain talking to inverse Miller
said that Boba was gonna be the main
villain in the next film that was the
set up while he was taking han solo away
why there was a thing with him in the
Christmas special according to Miller
Lucas decided to end the story with the
third movie so instead of setting up a
future fight between solo and feds Lucas
opted just to kill off the bounty hunter
Colonel Steven Hiller in the 1996
blockbuster Independence Day Will Smith
played Colonel Steven Hiller who ends up
giving a very memorable welcome to an
invading alien
welcome to earth almost two decades
later Smith is still one of the biggest
movie stars in the world with an almost
guaranteed box-office draw however in
2013 when the studio was gearing up to
enter pre-production on the Independence
Day sequel Independence Day resurgence
director roland emmerich told the New
York Daily News that he didn't expect
Smith to return saying he was simply too
expensive to hire to explain Smith's non
involvement in the movie 20th Century
Fox launched an interactive website that
explained that Colonel Heller died
during a military test flights in 2007
Quicksilver despite enormous success
Marvel Studios early movies don't seem
to hold much fateful danger for our
favorite super-powered heroes however
the Marvel Cinematic Universe finally
suffered a casualty in Avengers age of
Ultron when the speedy superhero
Quicksilver died saving Hawkeye and a
child from Ultron's attacks he didn't
see that coming at the time audiences
wondered why Quicksilver was the unlucky
Avenger to get killed off as it turns
out there were a couple reasons
according to Marvel Studios head honcho
Kevin Feige while talking to mtv news
states to the to the ending in the film
solidified scarlet witch's character
yeah and and Wanda's wanders arc in the
movie although the fact that 20th
Century Fox had its own very popular
version of Quicksilver and the x-men
movies might have been a factor as well
looks like there's only room for one
Quicksilver in Hollywood
[Music]